lou while you're in the government and
then there's sean while you're in the
government have you ever come across the
words element 115 did you see it did you
read it did you ever hear someone allude
to it so first of all kurt um
how you doing you doing good
good doing great everybody out there in
uh
in the uh social media world thank you
very much for having having me uh and
spending today's afternoon with me
um
don't i mean don't get me wrong i don't
mind kissing on the first date kurt but
uh just wanted to first say
thank you for having us on here and to
your audience for having us
uh two very quick uh today is a bit of a
special day for me my my daughter
uh taylor is getting married she's over
in california getting married to uh her
fiance joe and he's over in monterey
right now at the defense language
institute learning a language
and serving our country so a huge shout
out if i may to to him thank you for joe
for your service to our nation uh we are
eternally grateful and
uh taylor and joe congratulations
uh congratulations
yep no no
appreciate it uh and kurt uh you're
looking mighty spiffy today so um just
for you
and sean we break the ice a little bit
uh and sean thank you for
for always your your friendship uh and
and you know being being with me um it's
it's profoundly appreciated then one
last big thanks to all the folks out
there
who continue to to support
uh this effort moving forward um there's
a lot of folks in the uk that are trying
to to do what we've done here in the
united states so a big shout out to them
and finally a big shout out to to all of
you in the audience thank you so very
much for being here with us uh it is
truly an honor and privilege now
now that we've got that out of the way
kurt let's answer your question about
element 115 um no um
there is obviously a lot of discussion
about it in the uh twitterverse and
social media but that was never
a part of the the the a-tip portfolio
doesn't mean it wasn't part of
portfolios beforehand or perhaps you
know some other efforts uh that were
parallel or tangential to atip but while
i was native element 115 wasn't ever
really part of any type of discussion
sean
i never no i never encountered anything
like that i wouldn't have um even if it
were purportedly
anything like what it's supposed to be
i've only heard about it in the
zeitgeist of ufology from the same
sources